i did an interview the other day it was
a local news interview i think it was in
the bay area super nice but and it was
not like a political show because she
immediately went to
the 2024 presidential because that's
where people's minds go and so we talked
about that and i covered why and i said
but you know there are 500 000 races i'm
saying a lot of the things we've said on
this on this podcast
and then she said okay well i want to
ask you a follow-up question
some people are saying that they are
worried that the forward party will take
votes from the other two parties and i
would like to know how you'd respond to
that and i said
yes that's our plan we are going to do
that
we're a political party
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to forward
political
startup guru advisor to the forward
party on coalition building an
all-around awesome activist and champion
for democracy lucy caldwell welcome lucy
hey andrew it's fun to be with you how
are you you kidding you and i hang out
all the time in churches in chicago
in airports in conference rooms so you
have a really fascinating path uh
thrilled to be working with you to build
forward um this is a very open-ended
question but how the heck did you get
here
and one of the things i really want to
dig into and it should have been part of
your intro
is you were the campaign manager for
joe walsh's 2020 anti-trump presidential
campaign so you and i met in iowa back
in the day yeah well the short answer to
your question of how the hell did i get
here is my
my in
sort of perennial reliable masochism no
[Laughter]
no i i got here because i got my start
working in politics i came up on the
right side of the aisle i came up in
conservative politics i ran some
campaigns i lobbied in 30 some states i
really was a
young
wide-eyed libertarian that i just found
at the time that the republican party
was the place that was the best home for
me and my ideas
in the public square and along the way i
got out of direct politics to start a a
company called crowd scout which was a
data platform for campaigns and issue
advocacy groups and non-profits and so i
was out of direct politics from 2014 to
2019. you took a you took a five-year
break and somehow got wrapped back in
i took a i took a five year break but
the
butt is a big but which is that we had
political clients and we were a
non-partisan company but i had come from
the right and the right was really
underserved in technology at the time
so we wound up functionally with a ton
of republican clients so we had seven of
the 17 republican presidential
candidates in 2016 we had all the
committees and so i was watching from
the sidelines but also watching
how the culture was changing within some
of those organizations like my client
the republican national committee and
was horrified
um but yes because of the masochism when
we sold that company i went to
nev some never trump folks that people
have heard of people like sarah longwell
and bill crystal and i said
how can i help can i help you think
about your data strategy and can i help
you build this ecosystem i'm looking for
something to do
and a month later i was in iowa with joe
walsh so
there you have it wow um well uh for
those of you people who aren't familiar
with um with sarah longwell she's a
never trump
uh republican who now is leading uh an
awesome org
uh called the the bulwark
um and then bill crystal is another very
prominent never trump uh commentator so
you go to them and say hey guys how can
i help and then they connect you to joe
yes exactly i went to drinks with sarah
um
we had drink we met for drinks in dc to
catch up sarah and i went way back we'd
worked on issues together in sort of
conservative policy world years before
and she said to me
have you heard of joe walsh
and i said
i think so
the guy
yeah
and she said well we think he should run
for
president he's going to run for
president and um he really needs someone
to run his campaign and could you talk
to him i think you could do it all right
wait wait let's get let's let's get a
date on this like uh what when was this
really
true i mean the the timeline is insane
this was like probably in the first week
of august of 2019
and wow that's really late but i just
wanted level set for you by that time
i've been on the trail for a year and a
half but continue
well the never trumpers were just like
flailing trying to find people to run
and i i went to
i went i flew to
illinois where joe
is from where he'd been on congressman
from illinois a couple of days later
and then um i went on a very brief
vacation with my husband from to tulum
like a five-day vacation which was the
vacation that was sort of like i promise
i won't be on my phone
you know this is going to be so romantic
we're going to be in a beautiful casino
with a plunge pool you know phones off
just wonderful romantic trip i worked
the entire time and we built a very
scrappy campaign apparatus and by the
next weekend um we announced joe
announced on um
uh george stephanopoulos show in in new
york and it was such a scrappy operation
at that time and it really was a scrappy
operation forever but a really scrappy
operation at that time that i was in the
green room
at abc with joe and
joe's wife and
chris christie was on the show that day
so chris christie was there just like
wanting to talk my ear off about
you know how how bad trump had been to
him that kind of thing and so joe is on
and about to make this announcement
and i i'm thinking like okay we're gonna
have to make sure that everything gets
turned over right like the website
the payment processor
and so i'm in this green room and all
these people like this is very exciting
i'd love to talk to you about this i'd
love to give you some advice and i think
that'd be great but at the same time i'm
just like opening my computer trying to
make sure like is the website live like
i'm like updating joe's twitter profile
it was a wild wild ride it didn't really
get less wild but
here we are well lucy i need to put you
in touch with uh my campaign manager
zach grauman because you guys could
share war stories
yeah but we never got a bus so you
graduated out of the the scrappy you
know
shop in a good way because you had so
much success and we were always on a
kamikaze campaign so
i did eventually have a much larger team
who could do things like push updates to
social platforms but
it was it was a wild ride all right so
first
who were the other candidates who were
considering taking on trump in the
republican party in 2020 was there
anyone aside from joe i well there were
other candidates who did that and
actually some of them are involved with
forward um you know you had former
massachusetts governor bill weld um oh
yeah bill weld was in that yeah continue
he's great yeah you very briefly had um
former south carolina governor and
congressman mark sanford
uh yeah but he kind of announced and
then receded very very quick right he
did he did he did and he was literally
like like five days or something or like
one week it was probably longer than
that but it was it was a small operation
it was a small operation and i think it
was mostly to
to raise awareness of you know an issue
that he's passionate about which was the
national debt but at the time that
seemed a little bit i mean i have a lot
of respect for mark sanford but it
seemed a little uh toned up just like
well we're kind of trying to make sure
that democracy
is which is on fire doesn't collapse and
the national debt conversation good to
have but not the conversation that we're
looking to have at this moment um but
there were a lot of republicans that i
think people thought might get in
people like larry hogan the governor of
maryland or mitt romney who needs no
introduction and it's really odd to look
back on that i mean that was just three
years ago but at the time we had this
idea
as the
first impeachment began when when the
revelations from the the fateful call
uh the fateful ukraine call came out and
uh alex minman came out as a
whistleblower we thought wow
more republicans are going to get in now
right like this is this is like going to
be a game changer this is the end this
is going to be the end for trump now the
dam is burst and we actually had this
feeling what should we do as a campaign
if a if another major republican like a
john kasich or mitt romney you name it
gets in should we try to get organized
and coalesce around one candidate we
were trying to make all these
considerations expecting that other
people were going to
put their hand up and meet the moment
and we still had you know the deadlines
because you ran for president there were
still months to go for filing deadlines
at the time that that happened between
then and people could still get in the
race and people on the dem side were
still getting in the race at that point
and so we had this idea that we were
going to suddenly be in a crowded field
of patriotic republicans standing up
against trump and
you know we all know how that turned out
no one no one came and in fact they
coalesced around trump in a way that was
really weird and we could even see it in
the grassroots uh folks in places like
iowa like we don't like him
he's he's not a he's not a good guy but
he's our guy and and actually the tone
among republicans in on the campaign
trail got so much worse in that fall
well well i mean that's profound and
that's something that has very very uh
you know big
implications for what we're seeing right
now
there are also implications for what
might happen in the democratic party if
for example
um joe biden runs again as an incumbent
which i expect to happen personally
and then there is some thought that oh
like someone's going to primary i
personally think no one primaries him
because
if you're a democrat particularly if
trump's coming up the other side
and you run against joe the incumbent in
a democratic primary you're going to be
seen as aiding
trump i think that there are really very
very powerful dynamics that keep people
from challenging the leader of the party
yeah and in the case of joe biden some
of it is ageism there is some ageism
going on in how people talk about
whether or not joe biden should continue
as the leader of the democratic party
and we i mean that just is the thing
that people don't say
but should there be healthy competition
in a party
at all times i think so and is it good
to have one president who albeit is
pro-democracy and not a demagogue not an
authoritarian like trump to have up in
joe biden a person who has stood up but
maybe does also think that he alone
can fix it
right is that healthy probably not
um but i think it's a
multifaceted landscape to say the least
when you say he alone can fix it he
alone can defeat trump was always his
thesis and i i hung out with joe a fair
amount on the trail people may not you
know and i know but if you're out on the
trail you run into each other all the
live long day because
because there are only so many
uh events union halls fish fries uh
cattle calls like you name it i mean
you're you're around each other all the
time and the dynamic of the republican
party it's fascinating to hear that you
thought at the time like oh
um this is going to be the damn bursting
you're going to have the kasich's the
romney's the elder statesmen of the
party decide to get in
the fact that that didn't happen doesn't
surprise me uh like but were there
moments during that time where you
thought okay
uh like
the atmosphere is going to change uh or
was it fairly consistent were there
moments where joe was like okay like
we're gonna take advantage of this well
before the first impeachment we were
talking very uh
extensively with a whole lot of groups
who are really focused on iowa joe is
from illinois stayed over
he went to college in iowa so we thought
great you know this is these are his
people these these nice white
iowans this is joe walsh's base we're
gonna connect with these people
and we did and we were having
conversations with endorsements that
matter in a republican primary people to
give endorsements like the cattlemen
right these are important endorsements
in iowa
and so i do think that we were hoping it
would change in a different way and it
changed in the worst way and it
culminated on caucus night and the
republican caucus
in iowa works a little differently than
the democratic caucus which is that in
the republican caucus you still have
people coming in and they come up and
they talk but then it is a secret ballot
which i hoped would be helpful in a year
like that also because you can show up
wherever
who's gonna show up to a republican
caucus in a year where on the democratic
side if you're a nice moderate voter or
just like a nice person who doesn't feel
tribal then in you know the year 2020
when you have so many really great
candidates and exciting candidates and
people who have a positive vision
of the future
why would you
go to the republican caucus so there
were some just structural problems
what was the turnout of the republican
caucus so one of the things i tell
people and most people don't realize
this
is that uh something like 6.4 percent
of iowans participated in the democratic
caucus
uh it's a very very low percentage uh do
you know what that percentage was on on
your side
i don't know the percentage offhand
right now at this moment it's i knew at
one time but much much lower and so i
went you know you divide your team up
and you try to send your candidate to
the biggest caucus site so like joe went
to ames and then you send your best
surrogates to the next
caucus sites and so i was oh i went to a
caucus site and had the unhappy
experience of getting blown out in that
caucus site while i was standing there
and people were
i mean that you know i think i left
before the voting show
yeah joe and bill weld were at a caucus
site where lara trump was there and all
of the trump people that night made
the same speech of course and trump
didn't go to a caucus site which is
really notable so they all delivered a
speech to each caucus site and of course
he couldn't have been it all of them but
he could have come to iowa trump barely
ever went to iowa but
they all delivered these speeches like
the the president wishes he could be
here and we're all going to keep america
great because people forget that the
second the second campaign the slogan
was actually kag
keep americans
so joe got up and joe is like a fire and
brimstone kind of guy i mean this is
like a former tea party congressman who
himself was once a trump supporter and
he got up and he said
um i just want you to have you know
donald trump lies to people he's not
honest and i want you to have a
president who
who
tells you the truth and people booed joe
out i mean getting up physically
approaching him
like mob it was like a mob scene and joe
has told me that that was really the
first time that he felt
physically truly unsafe
and um my husband was with joe that
night because you again very scrappy
campaign i realized that i had sent
joe's the person who had been staffing
joe i had sent that person to another
caucus site like i just needed to spread
people out so i said to my husband he'd
come in for that week i'm like you've
got to go with joe and joe and my
husband are forever bonded because of
the fear and sense of lack of just
physical safety in that room i was a few
miles away at a caucus site where the
person who had come to show up on
trump's behalf
was brad parscale
and brad parscale was there
um
in a dark suit looking quite ominous
with a large team and as brad was giving
his pitch
to the uh to the people sitting in this
gymnasium middle school
the trump
team
flanked out sort of fanned out around
brad and walked down the aisle of this
middle school gym cafeteria place
whatever and started placing keep
america great red caps on the children
in the rooms people will bring their
kids to a caucus site to see
you know you're seeing democracy in
action it's cool
just not i'm this is going to make me
sound like i'm really really like a
snowflake but didn't ask the parents for
mentioning just it was this show of
force like we are putting these caps
on your kids right and i thought this is
a this is a cult
well that does seem kind of
indoctrinationy you know like we're
we're going to
christen them in a particular way
um so
so you guys announce in august the
caucus is in february that gives you
about six months
of campaigning
uh what proportion of the time did you
spend in iowa and i want wanna share
that i
i was all over the place but i came and
went to iowa i think i counted it was
like 24 times um and sometimes i would
go through chicago
um
and so when you say illinois is next to
iowa i remember like minnesota was north
of us i came in and out of minneapolis
sometimes um so there were times when
um we would do campaign events in
chicago
because it seemed proximate and i also
had these
uh visions that maybe we could get
enough people in illinois excited to
volunteer to come over to iowa and
canvas
so so what did the joe walsh campaign
look like operationally where were you
in illinois fundraising and you'd come
back to iowa were you in dc a lot like
did you crisscross all over were there
pockets of
joewall support in new york and
california yes we actually did wind up
spending a lot of well we spent most of
our time
in iowa
and we did not spend very much time in
new hampshire in part because we had i
mean we had to work with the weld team
right we were bill weld is from
massachusetts easy for him to go up to
new hampshire and super under resource
campaigns there almost started to be
like a division of labor right like you
go
keep the voices loud and cultivate
people in new hampshire and we will
focus on iowa and both campaigns did go
to both places but we had this idea it
wasn't we weren't like directly planning
this but it was obvious it just makes
sense you're from the neighboring states
and it's easier yeah right
so we did spend a lot of time in places
like la new york and dc and the reason
that we did that is that one thing even
as fundraising was very hard it was very
challenging and another thing that was
happening at this time is that the
republican party began cancelling
primaries
so oh yeah i mean they literally
canceled the primaries so at some point
it was i mean you start in a kamikaze
campaign like that she's like okay well
here's the path and i told joe the whole
time i said when i took him on i said
this is a very long shot campaign we
know what we're doing here but you do i
need you to look me in the eye
and say that you're prepared to be
president you have to be running to be
president this can't be we know the
reality here and so we would talk about
that path right it's important to talk
that way and at some point we stopped
having a path because there were
literally so many primaries cancelled
and this is not like joe walsh's vermin
supreme right like bill weld and joe
welch are former republican elected
officials i mean bill weld is one of the
most beloved former governors
and so it was unheard of completely
crazy but so we stopped having a path
but so that in it we became this cycle
where fundraising was so much harder
everything was so much harder it's like
what am i what am i supporting here
but we spent a lot of time in new york
and dc because the one thing that i had
in joe walsh as a candidate was an
amazing stage presence and an amazing
ability to go on tv and rile people up
in a good way and so you know the reason
we did something like
launch on a sunday show and continue to
prioritize doing tons of media
was not because joe didn't want to be
out talking to the people he loves that
and he's actually a person who could
spend you know five hours in like uh you
know like a feed store and actually
hates being at a fundraising event right
like actually hates being with the
chattering class but i knew that that
was the way that we were going to get
into people's veins was by just sort of
hitting the media machine over and over
and over and over again
[Music]
so the the fact that the republican
party did start canceling primaries i do
remember that um i actually have a
belief that we may see something similar
in the democratic party this cycle where
if joe runs as an incumbent and he has a
challenger let's say marianne williamson
that the democratic party wants
absolutely nothing to do with that
they'll just be like you know what
let's skip it uh i i think there's a
real chance of that personally because
everyone knows that jimmy carter had a
very significant primary challenge and
then lost in the general and so
there is like well also a lot of people
compared to obama to jimmy carter for a
number of reasons but um but there's
going to be a lot of pressure for the
democrats to avoid any kind of
competitive primary
well there's a you and i have talked
about this before and you've put it well
but it's true that i so i hate both
sides of them about the two parties
because it's just not true i mean one
party is
being taken over by
fascists and the other party is not
meeting the moment right that's part of
why work like the work of the forward
party is so important but but you know
saying we need a new way doesn't mean
that i think that you know like the two
of my current parties are the same yeah
totally not at all not at all totally
but i do think that you put this i heard
you say this a couple of weeks ago and
you put it really well
it expresses the same idea which is that
when one party is taking us down the
long slide to
authoritarianism
both parties become vulnerable and and
and and i was at a in a briefing a
couple of days ago
um by a person who's worked all over the
world trying to help stabilize
democracies for years and he said you
know one of the big challenges is
for example in a scenario where
trump won this is a worst case scenario
right like you have a
a trump biden match up again and trump
wins
and you know that trump himself is a
person who may never give up power he
may do everything in his
power to
you know take control of the military do
things that are that's the end that's
the end for us then you could be
a pro-democracy like want nothing more
than to have free and fair elections
democrat and you could start to feel
like
joe biden shouldn't
participate in the peaceful transfer of
power because then joe biden is
handing over the keys to
this fascist right and so you can start
to see how
good people
can start to take part in things that
are anti-democratic like canceling
primaries right that it is all
in the service at that moment
of what feels like in service of the
long game that is preserving our
american democracy but that in fact
is actually very dangerous because
you then in order to meet the moment
of
fighting back against authoritarianism
you have to start making compromises and
doing things yourself that
make you
accomplish uh complicit in that that
work and that's why something like
forward is so important because right
now those are our only levers that's our
choice those are really bad options
yeah i i agree with you completely one
thing i find consistently frustrating is
people are like
you know uh the both sides ism the like
oh you know like why are you lumping
these two parties together and it's like
look of course i think most most people
think that what's going on with the
parties are very very different i mean
the republican party is to me now
uh an authoritarian cult and it's
something that's going to persist well
past trump in my opinion i feel like
there are now at this point a half dozen
errors to trumpism
that are that are channeling a lot of
like the same they're worth uh yeah yeah
they may even be worse because in some
cases their confidence level might be a
little higher um so uh
and then on the other side i mean if i
had to characterize the democrats you
know it's like an unaccountable
tone-deaf bureaucracy that is
condescending and preachy and willing to
uh and and and it's also overrun by
uh corporate interests of its own
because in a two-party system it's
pretty easy for a company just to be
like you know what i'm just going to
give both of you and like let's just
keep you keep everyone off my back
you and i were on a phone call a couple
of weeks ago with a
well-known democrat and it was a pr it
was an off the record conversation so
i'm not going to share the person's name
but i'm i'm mentioning that because i
don't want to claim authorship of this
statement but he said something that has
stuck with me
uh that this is a person who wants
democrats to win would like to see the
democratic party be successful is a
person who's i think a politically
moderate person is very open right
and he said
republicans are insurrectionists and
democrats are aliens
and i that is really stuck with me i
keep i think about it every day
it's sort of it's reductionist but it's
kind of sums up
the thing right
it's kind of the whole thing
you know a technologist made a similar
statement to me lucy he said republicans
programming is closer to people's base
programming
whereas like democratic programming
requires a lot of explanation
yeah
yeah um and hence the alien comment
and and so
we do need something like forward uh to
be the
modernizing force uh to make our
democracy actually a true democracy and
more resilient sustainable like i i
don't regard the two parties as the same
but i regard the system as
uh doomed to fail so so you're toiling
with joe hopscotching across the country
uh you assign your husband to staff him
for caucus
so
um what are your
fondest and darkest recollections
of
those six months or so yeah some of my
darkest recollections are
having had some narrow hope that more
people would help me
um
and i had a huge huge network in
on the republican side that's the world
i'd come from and i'd had a lot of
republican clients and in fact some of
them had left the
rnc at that point and and so i started
to call them to just talk practically
about whether or not they would help
and i was met with a lot of so glad
you're doing this but i can't be a part
of it
and at one point profiles encouraged
exactly
at one point i was on the phone with
someone whom i've known
like since i was 17 we grew we went to
school together and
uh
he is a bachelor and i had just had
dinner with him my husband and i had
dinner with him a few weeks before and
it's like so unfettered and was like
talking to me about you know his travels
to he's a republican consultant you know
how he was taking these fabulous trips
and he just bought a new audi
and so i call him a few weeks later to
say hey man i'm doing this crazy thing
you're super smart and you've worked for
all the republicans who don't even exist
in this party anymore and you have some
tools and and tactics and in your quiver
that i could really use and can you help
me and we'll pay you of course
you don't want to do that you'd be an
advisor and i just i just had dinner
with this person a few weeks before it's
a very very old friend and he said to me
you know i'd love to but the thing is
people have all these considerations
like people have kids and they have a
mortgage
and i thought
okay but you you don't
howdy
so that was one of the most
disappointing things and and the feeling
of that it was really invasion of the
body snatchers i mean just awful um much
more so i mean that had happened in 2016
and i'd already seen that but it is so
much i really think it's hard to
remember
how much worse it gets all the time and
how in the year 2019 we thought maybe
there could be i mean people like i like
me thought that like maybe the
republican party could still be rescued
and so that
that's some of my darkest
memories sure some of my fondest
memories is that the relationships that
i've formed since then
with people who were former republicans
so-called never trumpers um
are
really
really meaningful relationships and
a real sense of kind of like uh well
we're all we're all we're like
the boat has capsized and we're on so we
might as well be ourselves it's very
freeing actually and i really
love those people and the fact that this
work has caused me
in subsequent years to really become
form some deep
professional relationships and
collaborative
uh dynamics with democrats who are
actually much more aligned with me than
we might have ever thought
that's
really wonderful i really love the
people that i'm in this fight with and
feel
happy they i like being around them they
make me feel good it's stimulating it's
it's exciting it's forward thinking i
love that
yeah i love it too
and that that brings us to our work with
forward
yeah so
um first kudos to you for stepping up uh
to
try and uh avert trump's
return
for being courageous and principled
genuinely patriotic doing something
that's in the nation's interest that's
not narrowly in one in one's own
self-interest i mean like you you have
legions of people who've made a very
different decision
and on one level you don't blame them
but on another you're just like hey guys
uh you know uh character
you know
like
genuine independence like you know
courage like you know you want to do
something you might actually feel good
about later um so so kudos to you for
doing the difficult thing and i agree
with you that when you do the difficult
noble thing you wind up making common
cause with people that you're bonded
with for life and you've stayed in the
fight even after the 2020 race
um
so
the three organizations that have now
merged to form the new forward party
renew america and serve america you were
involved with with renew i was not ever
involved in with renew in a staff
capacity but i i was i took part in a
lot of their early conversations i'd
been and that that's the world i come
from right the world of disaffected
republicans and conservatives and
independents who had hoped that there
could be a different lane i think one of
the things they ran into is that it's
sort of like the the buddhist cap size
so now we might as well be ourselves
that that group didn't naturally form
a clear constituency you know the the
idea of we were bonded before because we
were republicans but we were all making
these
concessions to other people on their
issues right so if you then try to bring
together people who may separately be
kind of dogmatic on a handful of issues
like you have the neocons in the room
and maybe the social conservatives and
then you have like the taxationist theft
people
and because it's not the case that all
never trumpers
are people who are like squishy moderate
republicans that's just not true and i
mean some of them are culture warriors
right
and so you know i think that that that
group renew one of the things they found
that they found and i'm saying this is
an outsider who i wasn't running the
organization but is that
there was less
natural alignment right they were
aligned on something very important but
if the work was to then go
reform the republican party they all had
to be thinking do i even want to reform
the republican party is that even the
thing that i want to be a part of and
we're all untethered by our former
the the our former bonds to the
republican party um but so i think it
was i was delighted when
i you know got got together with my
friend miles taylor and he said
we're gonna do this crazy thing i
thought great how can i how can i help
you do that yeah miles said that early
on they had a a
meeting where they said hey guys do you
think we should try and
reform the republican party or just form
a new
party and it was 50 50. and they said
okay i guess we'll try and reform the
republican party and see if that works
and now people have concluded that it's
not working and by the way any news
flash it's not working uh at this point
you have right uh
you know seven out of ten of the
republicans voted to impeach trump who
are out or going to be out soon um liz
cheney's probably going to lose uh
pretty pretty soon and liz we want to
talk to you about joining joining
forward i that will shock absolutely
nobody
[Laughter]
um so trump's hold of the party just
gets stronger the latest uh fbi raid
news has only
uh strengthened that dynamic where there
are a number of
uh republicans who are looking at taking
him on in the presidential who i think
just saw their hopes dim
frankly
and some of them are still looking for a
way to be of service and to run
one of the the things you all ran into
and this is one of the big cases forward
is making is like look there are a lot
of people that would choose someone
other than trump even within the
republican party they just might not
vote in a republican primary where if
you look at the five to ten percent of
voters who are
uh party activists like that's a very
very different version of the public
than let's say you know 100 percent uh
of the voting population um so there are
a bunch of moderate republican types or
independent types who i think are
looking to run for president but don't
think the republican primary is the way
to do it yeah yeah i mean one of the
challenges for the republican party is
that only a third of republican voters
mostly when polled think that joe biden
won the election um and so that means
functionally that to get through a
republican primary you have to be
a person who's willing to participate in
the big lie
and that also has
is a reflection of the fact that people
who live who
who don't take part in that horrible
part of that has become the dominant
culture in the republican party
are leaving the republican party i grew
up in arizona and this isn't just
happening at the top of the ticket and i
mean i think part of what's so powerful
about forward is that we're saying there
are 500 000 elected offices right and
there are mayor's races and there are
state legislative races and city council
races and governor a lot of races a lot
of races a lot of races beyond the
presidency a lot of races beyond the
senate and the u.s house of
representatives i grew up in arizona and
uh people who are followers of
of election results know that
last week in arizona my home state was
an absolute bloodbath every republican
endorsed by trump won
the uh top of the ticket
the gubernatorial candidate carrie lake
is literally talking about how arizona
should secede from the union uh mark
fincham the presumptive the the
republican nominee for secretary of
state um is a member of the oath keepers
and was there on january 6 was part of
the the group that stormed the capital
the state lawmakers including people
like rusty bowers who was the former
speaker of the house in arizona who
actually had the courage to testify
uh in the january 6 hearings
he was he
stood the line held the line he was
defeated every republican who's ever
said a bad word about trump other than
some people running at the county level
they were blown out and so people look
at a state like arizona and they say
wait we thought we were into arizona we
thought arizona was like this cool kind
of purple turning blue state what's
happening and the answer is it is that
state it actually is but our system is
so
screwed up
that now you have these
a really hardened base
choosing the republican candidates and
then we're all just forced to choose
between the republican candidates and
the democratic candidates who have their
own issues because they're also turning
people out at the polls polls as in the
extremes p-o-l-e-s
and so yeah you could wind up in a state
that was heroic in the eyes of people
who care about democracy
last year
in in 2020 right and it's the same
people living it's the same good people
living in that state it hasn't changed
it's probably if anything it's gotten
more liberal but
but that's that's the problem right that
is like a that's like a case study
for why we need different and more
lovers in this system yeah uh that is
dark it's true the the trumpian take
over the republican party of arizona uh
and and you're you're seeing
similar types of candidates prevail all
over the place one of the themes of the
last couple of weeks was that
occasionally democrats have boosted them
like the way they boosted peter meyer's
uh opponent
um
uh because they said hey this extremist
will be more beatable in the general so
what if they're an election denier so
what if they're like a threat to
democracy let's spend a million bucks
and like get them in into the general so
you and i have been in a bunch of
meetings um with the forward party what
have you been seeing and hearing i
actually you know would love to hear
this in real time because uh you know i
don't know the latest yeah i think that
one thing that i'm seeing and hearing is
that people are really excited about
some of the structural commitments that
the forward party is making i think that
they're really it really resonates with
people that we're making commitments
about outcomes and not prescribing the
tactics right you know in in our current
policy
uh landscape it becomes a fight between
one party's proposed tactic and another
and the outcomes like
you name it right having
healthy communities having access to
clean air uh you know being able to have
a a context that gives way to
successful entrepreneurship being able
to start a business being able to care
for your young kids being able to make
sure that they're getting a high quality
education
there there isn't a lot of there's not a
a commitment to out those outcomes
there's a fight about which tactic we
should use and then no one comes out of
that thinking like gosh we just spent
another legislative session fighting
we actually have not achieved any of
those means and so i think it's
resonating with people not the pundit
class but it's resonating with people
that commitments about
helping to empower people to choose what
kind of communities they live in what
kind of solutions work for them and
working together
i think is
is really powerful i was on the phone
with um a couple of days ago with people
who work in the bridging community you
know work to bridge um left and right
helped to
work on things like deliberative
democracy and
they said to me and this was it was kind
of like a meet and greet phone call and
they said
they began by saying after intros lucy
what can we do
to help the forward party
and i said i'm not skirting your
question but what i actually want to
talk about is what can the forward party
do
to help you how can we help your work
because the the party any political
party
is just should be a means to an end it
should be meaningful enough to have
influence but it actually should be
as small and empty a vessel as possible
because it's a tool by which to
make people's lives better make our
communities the communities we want to
live in and they were taken aback by
that but i think that that is something
people are taken aback with about but
then when they think about it they're
like oh yes
in our current party system not just the
two major parties third parties all the
parties they're just about power so
ultimately pretty quickly the parties
become this thing where what is first is
are we in power and the people that
matter
get lost and i think another thing that
people really like about the forward
party that i hope becomes part of our
cultural dna
is you know how people will say these
things people like you and
people like us like no one says this to
us because they're just like they're
crazy people but you know the idea that
you shouldn't talk about religion or
politics you know like in with your a
person that you meet a stranger
and
that doesn't work for people who spend
their lives doing it someone's like what
do you do for a living we're having a
conversation about politics at that
point no lucy i mean
it's it's uh it's one degree worse for
me because uh yeah people they know you
they they
they'll talk about politics immediately
i've traveled with you now so i know
like walking through an airport someone
a stranger you know we're like where's
the car rental place like we're talking
about actually now we're talking about
politics but why shouldn't we be talking
about politics politics drives so much
of our lives and the the reason that we
can't talk about politics is that we
don't trust each other or trust
ourselves to be able to talk about
politics in a way that isn't really
tribal and dysfunctional so part of the
commitment that the forward party is
making is that
we could have disagreements like you
could characterize something in a way
that i disagree with and we could talk
about it we could talk about it on a
podcast we could talk about it right
here we could talk on a stage and it
wouldn't mean that we've become
mortal enemies
right
it would mean that reasonable minds can
disagree and that we might disagree on
how to get to an outcome
[Music]
i'm i'm very very sensitive though lucy
i don't know if you just i know uh you
know well i know i might
i know yeah i i mean that that is the
best thing about the fourth part it's
really
yeah i know it's very much come as you
are uh you know and when i spoke to a
conservative republican in west virginia
on a zoom he was like oh man
conservative republicans yeah i'm just
kidding
someone even better the job so yeah you
said mr yang i don't think i can join
your party because i'm a conservative
coal miner republican here in west
virginia virginia and i said look we can
disagree on all sorts of things as long
as you agree the two-party system's not
working and that the republican party is
not actually
exactly
you know solving the problems you're
seeing around you then we'd love to have
you on forward and literally 45 seconds
later he was like all right i'm in you
know
it was and it made me feel so good
a lot of americans don't
don't think that uh one party wants them
because we might disagree on something
and forwards very much the opposite it's
like well we want you
we don't care if you agree or disagree i
think someone said we're not going to
check your id at the door another thing
about forward two that's kind of funny
is people say like hey can i keep my
party registration and then we're like
well right now you technically can't
even register with ford in your state
probably i'm sure
you know like i mean we're gonna get
there like you know eventually we'll
have valid access at various places yeah
uh 15 states by the end of this year
but in in the interim i mean we're
building a broad popular inclusive
movement uh and we need people to to
join and i think that that's like even
that's a different message than the
parties right now the parties seem like
they're just like throwing up various uh
litmus tests and gates in a particular
way and a lot of it's a call to action
being like hey you know you know what
unifies us is like we can't stand those
people
yeah
yeah and we're like look you know we we
understand there are problems but you
know we we love other people
totally i think that come as you are
thing is that's a really good way to
describe it and both parties do this but
i've seen i've spent several years
trying to help democrats get people
elected
um to get democrats elected and it's a
little bit like head banging against the
wall all the time because i've also seen
the way that they'll have someone just
who's like trying to join them right
maybe
like a suburban mom who usually votes
republican but really cares about um
preserving
choice like really just is is activated
by the idea that
you know she wants to make sure that
there's access to
safe and legal abortion in her state and
she doesn't want to see a heartbeat bill
and she wants to make sure there's
access to birth control i've watched
over and over again
in individual interactions and at scale
just i'm deliberately choosing a
controversial issue to make the point
i've watched democrats do things like
okay here's this woman look she's going
to be in your column she's going to only
vote for democrats this year because she
so cares about this issue
and instead of being like great we're so
glad you're here
they're like okay
you are now in the engagement funnel
where you must make a lot of commitments
about why and how your view came to be
and you must agree that all republicans
are trying to
control women
that is what they're trying to do it's
not just the downstream effect that's
what they're trying to do and you also
must agree now that you could never you
will never support any limit on abortion
like you want you know and it's like
that's not how people feel like no one
feels that way right and so then
suddenly it's like oh gosh i actually
don't want to be with those people
so
that dogmatic attitude where you can't
even you can't be a supporter like
you're not even allowed to be a
supporter unless you make a whole bunch
of signals
that is a thing that people are for sure
sick of like exhausted of and you're
gonna see that showing up i think in a
lot of local races state legislative
races gubernatorial races where people
there are some candidates doing that
already that's happening in oregon
there's an independent candidate in
oregon running for governor who is
polling
even with the democrat right she may win
right oregon
so yeah
betsy johnson sure i met with betsy last
month
uh feel free to check out betsy johnson
i i'm supporting betsy so i obviously
yeah i'm excited about that but
[Laughter]
did you have you met betsy she's great
i haven't but some really fabulous
people who are campaign operatives that
i've done a lot of work with over the
years who've come from my sort of
background are working with her so i
hear a lot about
stories from their trail
yeah it is fun
uh having leaders like you trying to
help people like betsy
and evan mcmullin
and bill walker and clint smith
uh and uh these other independents and
it does
irk me somewhat to to your earlier point
that like people are all obsessed about
the presidential it's like look there's
a ton of stuff we can do right now
that's going to have a lot of impact in
various communities and it's just so
like it does piss me off that the press
just resorts to like this laziness
because it suits their their ends i mean
their ends are like look i just want to
keep you in that corner and you know you
hate him you hate them send us money
click on our stuff oh wait third party
wait that might interrupt our narrative
like uh no no bad bad
i did an interview the other day it was
a local news interview i think it was in
the bay area super nice
reporter anchor but it was not like a
political show right and uh she wanted
to ask she immediately went to the 2024
presidential because that's where
people's minds go and of course the
involvement of people like you in this
as as someone who's a founder and a
leader in this that makes their minds go
to that um and so we talked about that
and i covered why and i said but you
know there are 500 000 races i'm saying
a lot of the things we've said on this
on this podcast
and then she said okay well i want to
ask you a follow-up question
some people are saying that they are
worried that the forward party will take
votes from the other two parties and i
would like to know how you'd respond to
that and i said
yes that's our plan we are going to do
that
we're a political party
we are absolutely going to take votes
but it's like you're seeing in real time
i then said her and you're saying this
in real time like oh everyone's in an
abusive relationship with the two
parties that is the parallel that is the
parallel for sure it's like like uh you
know this idea of like well i talked to
a democratic operative who said that
they're worried that the forward party
could
siphon democratic votes in you know xyz
little race and you know xyz place it's
like well you know what uh then that
democrats should work to make their
message more palatable
to
the voters competition is good it's good
for people to have choices we agree
about that in every area of our lives
that's so fundamentally american and the
thing that turns out to be
arguably the most deterministic about
what our communities and societies look
like
when it is voting and who represents us
and how do we elect our leaders
of itself ends up being by accident
completely anti-american so it's
interesting to watch people kind of
challenge their own programming that
they didn't even know was inside of them
i really love that
yeah the the the parallel truly is an
abusive
relationship where i was
joking with someone that's like it's
like that the primary defense of the
two-party system is to point out how
dysfunctional it is
you know i mean they'll be like oh i
mean it's strange
it's fun making it more american
alongside you if someone wants to follow
you lucy how do they do so well if
they'd like to follow me on twitter they
can do that at lucy m caldwell fantastic
excited to build this party alongside
you and thanks again for standing up for
what's right in the face of a lot of
pressure
and i'm sure adversity we owe you a
great deal and we are just getting
started
likewise andrew thank you so much this
has been fun